what's with the jeans hey what's up with
this guy oh what's wrong my headphones
fell off you don't have to shit right
now you have to yeah can we do the
shower do you need to take your purse
all this gossip going on about me and
Selena Gomez and I have been laughing
the whole time that's awesome yeah
that's really great what is that why is
that happening to me I don't even know
what what is that what's that what
happened I don't know it's just well you
know should happen sometimes me game
shit do you have to shit now or can we
do our show I know you shit 20 times a
day I don't know if this this show
impedes on your shooting schedule what
do you think of your dad and Selena go -
I keep telling Selena not to worry about
it I mean how creepy is this guy though
I don't like him
Selena Gomez is it she's like a teenager
or early 20s or something where she's
not interested in that guy you don't
think so the way that he holds his
microphone when he makes it like it's
annoying to me I think he's annoying
you think he's annoying yeah it's one of
those things like I will not let you
blow me like he's just making ya
attention we're going to talk about you
good or bad if a person gets mad they
get teased more I mean me and Selena are
famous so talk anyway then my 14 year
old son Jacob Parrott gets jealous and
mad so I have to sell him down
one of the things I think really funny
though is to make a video like this if
your kids being an asshole yeah cuz
imagine how upset his son like if his
sons a dick and he goes alright
no I'm just to you being like this and
he starts posting videos like this
imagine what a fourteen-year-old boy
would do terrible you know do you
remember poltergeist and that guy that
God is again yeah holy damn oh yeah that
old man huh
that's him I like this guy's laugh
though I could see you with a guy like
that
yeah yeah you got it I do I sometimes
like do you ever do that where you see
people and you go oh I could see my
spouse with them I see I see that
sometimes no actually I don't ya know
why cuz I thought sickens me if he were
to be with another woman I would fucking
kill both of you well I see a guy like
this and I go I see Christina and him
living together I see you guys making
out his mouth smells so bad he has a lot
of plaque on his teeth he doesn't do
even buy yearly cleanings yeah his mouth
is a it's a cesspool
yeah it's all yellow and it's all dad I
bet his penis is not the same color as
the rest of his skin yeah what color do
you think it is I think it's more yellow
than his actual skin I think it's purple
oh really yeah cuz if you look at the
rest of him he's got a purpley tones to
his disgusting gums and mouth it's
usually the same color as your penis I
think he has a liver deficiency and that
his penis and his testicles are yellow
now I got highlighter just yellow hues
the dick detectives I wish we could find
out the answer to this mystery that's
the thing we really need never know well
so you say my friend so you say I think
it's possible that we could find out
okay but you gotta be up for the
challenge
the dick detectives
bass guitar if I get a bass guitar yeah
don't boom-boom